[Music]
sergey is with us to start off this hour
in new york hi sergey what's up
hey how are you dave great man how can i
help
uh got a question for you about the
selling the house we've
never done it before uh we purchased the
house
now we are looking to purchase another
house planning on and
obviously question came up to sell our
house that we have right now
and uh
there's uh when we go through realtor
there's seven percent
we have to pay for selling our house
uh and since you know
i'm starting to started to listen to the
show and working on
uh eliminating our own debt and we've
done it
we finished the step two
so now we i always constantly me and my
wife we're always saying about you know
everything reasonably when we plan
things and everything
so now we plan about this and
there's seven percent and it bugs me i
don't have peace in my
heart to sell the house you're right
you're out of toothache
have you ever had a toothache
yes i did before absolutely
did you use pliers or a dentist
dentist okay there's some things you
don't do yourself because you don't know
what you're doing you told me you didn't
know what you're doing
right yeah i've had friends this is your
most expensive asset
when you make a mistake selling a piece
of real estate it ain't ten dollars dude
i mean when you make a mistakes on piece
of real estate it's tens of thousands of
dollars and you're in a whack-a-doodle
world right now for real estate it's
cray cray out there
the this ain't amateur hour man
you definitely want a pro in your corner
it's gonna save you more than seven
percent oh and by the way let me help
you with this it's not seven percent
three and a half because some duber
realtor will bring you an offer if
you'll agree to pay them for their
buyers portion of three and a half and
you're only going to end up saving the
sellers portion which is three and a
half and
and now we're really down into you're
gonna lose it a monkey can sell a house
right now
but will they sell it for the right
price and without a bunch of errors that
cost you tens of thousands of dollars
i wouldn't sell my own house right now
and i've had a real estate license since
i was 19 so since 1978
you're gonna make more
and you're gonna have a lot less hassle
and you know i i just i
i don't even work on my own cars anymore
i don't know i used to open the hood and
get a 9 16 and adjust the
i could watch this on youtube and fix it
myself well i mean there wasn't youtube
then but i mean i could set the timing
on the monte carlo 350 right i mean i i
could do all that i opened the hood now
and it looks like a freaking spaceship
under there i can't even touch that
stuff i don't fix every time i try to
fix my car now it costs me more than it
would have cost me to have somebody fix
my car because i break something
and that's what you're gonna do sergey
don't do it yeah i've i've had a family
member who did for sale by owner and it
was the worst nightmare and i had tried
to warn them to stay away from that but
there are such costly mistakes you make
you're not reaching the bigger market
because realtors have access to the mls
they take better photos they understand
strategy and staging and what is going
to cause someone to pay more money and
so in the long run you're going to make
more on that purchase by going to a
realtor well and here's the thing okay
let's pretend you get one of these
houses that people are going bananas
okay where you get like 60 offers or 40
offers or something
the seller it's almost impossible
emotionally for the seller to manage
that process
and and clean through that and get the
best possible deal and deal
professionally with the other 39 who
don't get the house
i mean you've got to have some
communication lines open you have to
have a process basically you're
conducting a freaking auction
in a lot of these situations and you've
got to know how to manage that
logistically and and what the law says
about it you'll get yourself in a pinch
man
i wouldn't do it i mean you can do what
you want to do but i think you're
getting a bargain at seven percent
uh if you get a good real estate agent
now i mean you've got uncle charlie who
got his license three weeks ago and he
wants you to do it because he's family
no charlie's dumb as you are don't do it
that you know he didn't know what he's
doing either no you get a high octane
high quality real estate agent that
knows what they're doing does a couple
hundred transactions a year when they
step in
i mean you're not you're never gonna
feel the tooth when it comes out
that's true and everyone who's worked
with one of those amazing realtors goes
that was worth every single penny i paid
them
one you get a bad one it's like anything
else but i mean
i and the same thing i mean i don't i
don't do my own taxes i don't do i don't
write my own will
i don't work on my own car and i don't
pull my own teeth
you know it's it's there's some things
and you've got all your teeth that tells
me yeah that's done well it's was
working out but the the diy thing
um i mean there's some things you feel
that way about and you're wrong and this
is one of them it's the actual
normal market data and i can't really
talk about it in this market but the
normal market data is that a realtor
sold house with a high quality real
estate agent will sell for more than
seven percent more
than the non-real estate agent sold
house that's normal in this world who
the crud knows i mean because you don't
even know what they're going to sell for
an asking price is now suggesting
starting point you know it doesn't mean
anything anymore asking price used to be
suggested starting point i'm going to
offer less you offer less you're not
getting the house you can forget it now
in most of these markets that's where
well and you're relying on a sign in the
yard and then uploading to whatever site
will allow you to upload your iphone
photos that were crappily taken and so
when you work with a realtor they know
the professional photographers they
understand how to stage it they
understand how to market it well they
understand every strategy around
contingencies and this is the kind of
market we're in
you're hiring a
marketing professional
for
seven percent
i mean and if you were doing something
else that was a 700 000 transaction
and it was a complicated transaction you
wouldn't think anything about paying the
attorney that did the transaction or
whoever whatever you it's part of the
process in a complicated thing
and i just highly recommend it all the
data that's out there in a normal market
says that you're worth that they're
worth it in this market they're probably
more than worth it and those of you
thinking about buying a house same deal
get you a good buyer's agent
because i mean if you go on
ramseysolutions.com and click on elp for
real estate endorsed local provider
ramsey trusted real estate agents that
we trust
they're all high octane we've vetted all
of them we know what they know what
they're doing we you know and if you're
gonna buy a house in this world you've
gotta
you know you gotta get some advice like
you have somebody go no those people are
going crazy walk away from that deal
that's a bad deal yeah you get too
emotional when it's just you yeah and
you get bought in on this one house and
you start to make stupid decisions yeah
good agent makes all the difference and
when you're dealing you know
man
it's it's it's definitely not amateur
hour right now um i would feel better
about you being a fizbo and i think
you'd have less damage in a normal world
but right now good gracious absolutely
not